John I know you've worked with Brendan
before in that wonderful 2011 of film
the guard
I'm wondering if you could talk about
what inspired you to create such an
extraordinary character for him in this
movie
um it was just as yeah it was as we were
finishing the garden go away
before we were going up to do a few days
shooting in Dublin we've just I had
always said I do making a film about a
good man a genuinely good person and
then we was starting you know knocking
it back and forth and now I was saying
you know they're probably going to make
because of all the scandals in the
Catholic Chur is going to make lots of
films about bad priests so maybe deal
with a good man who's a good priest
would be a way of making an original
film and you know Brennan had with Sony
dad a mentor when he was young and I
said okay well that's the way we
approach it you know and we do the exact
opposite probably what people are
expected and we follow a good man you
know no it was one of those kind of it
was great night John Cheadle was walking
around with a big bucket of Chinese in
the middle of spittle in in Connemara in
County Galway that nobody could
understand where he got it from from and
and we were with a great chat because it
was a very hard shoot and all that kind
of thing and we got down to that notion
of somebody who had you know there had
been a priest who was accused of
pedophilia in the wrong one or two of
them in the recent past and obviously
there been a lot of people a lot of them
of being accused justifying but I
remember talking about like our feeling
or when this whole thing abut how do you
deal with something when you're you know
being vilified for for trying to
dedicate your life to generosity and and
and all that it must be awful and one
thing led to another it was and he said
if I write it will you do it and I said
oh god yeah and then he just became this
amazing I wasn't quite expecting what
turned up I got to say well what
happened was I mean I did a yeah I I
always say I'll wake up with a hangover
I have to write the script pregnant goes
off and does another movie yeah but what
happened was so I did the first draft a
senator Brendon and B
was it our relationship on the guard you
know I would have never done that before
send an actor an hourly job and Brendan
said to me you know you know a lot I
have a tendency to be too detached into
so nihilistic there's a lot of talk
about detachment in the film as well and
Bren said you know there's lots of very
emotional scenes here particularly with
Kelly's character and the scenes were
there they were in the script but they
weren't as big as they became I think
and that was our back and forth because
I recognized that was missing and it and
now when I see the movies like what you
know why were why were those scenes not
as expansive as and emotional as they
should have been in the first draft but
at least we got there through the
dialogue eventually let me talk about
the incredible core of emotionalism
Kelly you and Brendan together have one
of the most amazing father/daughter
relationships the work I didn't feel
like work you begin with what's on the
page and then you kind of go away and
daydream about it and and then you meet
Brendan and you do the scenes and it's
not difficult it wasn't difficult I fell
in love with everything about this film
and I just watched the last 25 minutes I
didn't I saw it last at Sundance and I'm
still emotional from this film I every
time I I see more of it I am terribly
moved by it and this it reveals itself
to me so much more but to answer your
question it Brendan was my most favorite
human being to work with either thing
obviously we had a little bit rehearsal
but when Kelly walked on did the scene
you know memories fade you know that
that first scene I think myself and
Brendan look to each other they went
well that's fine we don't have to worry
about any performances there I mean
she's now that and we can move on a bit
and then as I always you know when
you're not giving notes to an actor does
that mean that they think they ignore me
for some reason am i doing something
wrong
no you're not giving notes because it's
actually completely perfect there's no
notes I have to give you know I was it
was a huge thing it was too you know
because the speed you're reading you
know and John sent me that draft
I knew father James at the core from his
great ship with his daughter that was
the one that was such tenderness and it
was such tragedy in it and and so that's
what you have and then when Kelley
arrived it just everything became the
her presence in the thing just completed
it in a way if it just became other than
words you know it just became something
else I wonder if we could talk about
that element of spirituality I know
you've been kind of offhanded saying
this is diary of a country priest the
great Robert breast saw a film with a
couple of gags thrown in but this is an
intensely spiritual film you've divided
up into seven days you've called it
cavalry do you want to talk about that
element yeah it's also we have you have
the seven-day stretch it's also loosely
structured around the five stages of
grief so it's denial anger bargaining
depression and acceptance so I had that
loose sort of structure as well I think
what I had in my mind was I was just
stunned everything about what you know
after what to do after the guard I
didn't want to wherever I was going to
do it would have humor in it but I want
to do something that was you know pretty
different to the guard just because just
a wrong foot and audience and I was just
thinking about you know all those you
know Ingmar Bergman you say of all those
movies in their 60s and early seventies
dealing with spiritual issues and
philosophical issues and I realized you
know no one just kind of doing that
anymore you know you know you talk about
Michael Bay is like well we can't
compete with Michael Bay in terms of
budget and explosions and CGI but we can
compete in a different way we can pee by
having a completely original story and
trying to do something people haven't
seen for a long time and that's the way
you compete you shot this movie in 29
days was that it and I'm wondering if
that short shooting period didn't
contribute to the intensity that we see
Oh Brendan hates a short shooting
schedule you know I kind of a crowd or
three whatever the count
dream and it's an artist's nightmare
frankly last week was appalling it was
six days a six-day week and we were
doing all the major scenes in the first
week more or less and of course the
finances once we done it then they gave
it two extra days because we've done
that in the first week but it was a very
intense we got absolutely hammered I
think on the Saturday night in a pub
that just you know I think it was
catatonic it was blackout drinking mines
no no you can talk to the yeah the
schedule
yeah no the schedule has become it's an
independent held really you know that's
what's happened is there because every
time a good movie comes from a short
schedule they shorten it again just to
see that's the absolute truth is not a
joke this is what they've absolutely do
they said my god they got that done ten
weeks has to be possible in eight like
the guard was along god is 35 so give
him 27 why not take seven off its he can
do it and and it becomes at some point
untenable and you know there was a huge
intensity I mean to address requests and
really there was a huge intensity but
there was a huge intensity at the
reading you know there was no this stuff
is not it's very personal to everybody
and my experience of how it has played
in Ireland and elsewhere is that is that
there's a there's a very personal
connection between everybody who watches
this film or everybody who's in it
every actor who came in and you know
there was one after another an amazing
cast coming in and it was a very
personal issue being explored with
everybody I absolutely certain out I
know it for it and so you know it was
always going to be intense it didn't
need there was one scene that kind of I
still you know again you get a gift we
were running out of you know and John is
amazing in terms of preparation and we
we do keep like we did save all the time
we had for what was on set there was not
there were no inefficiencies in terms of
well being just left hanging a belt for
no particular reason storyboards were
there the preparation was there the
weather maybe something you can't deal
with boudoir as a plan for that but the
scene which broke my heart you know and
always felt really important to me even
from the very beginning or from from
whenever I read at first it was one
where he talks to the girl
the road and he's accused of you know
inappropriate behavior and there's the
feeling of corruption and insidious
things suddenly enters her room when the
father who's beside himself looking for
his child suddenly sees what this
middle-aged cleric talking to my
daughter about it's one of the most
horrible that's the one that drives him
over the edge in a way it's one of my
favorite ones but we were that was
really being crushed for time and almost
we almost didn't kind of make it and I
think that's what happens in short
schedules like you have to let the damn
thing breathe and let people explore
like we got blessed whether we got
blessed with a lot of different issues
we were dead lucky to come out with it
if anything had gone wrong yeah in in
whether was or any otherwise we wouldn't
have made it really which so we got
lucky that things went right for us